Machinery yeah but I got a tar a bucket
of tar what the hell
maybe I Grif but wants it probably not
it's not going very well oh [ __ ]
I should stop taking damage do you mean
you at the end of the game and you don't
know what the red ooze is there what the
red what's the red the red goose the
rednecks I don't know
oh you mean that the red poop yeah the
red poop out I don't know I think it's
something to do with the shadow the [ __ ]
the shadow yeah that [ __ ] monster or
whatever why is that a shadow because
they I think they referred to him as a
shadow is haunting him it's a monster
yeah a lot of people are calling me a
song be also I don't know really it's
definitely not a shadow
well he's something at least
I need he's scary I don't like him this
place is so big won't budge I hate when
his sister
I've already been in here you know we
going no I have no idea actually
I came from down there yep it was
horrible down there I don't want to go
down there again uh here's a puzzle that
I don't get at all
it's not working something must be done
with the machinery and this isn't
working either something was done with
the machinery was there free works
was that
wasn't there a third one
was there are you kidding nothing maybe
might as well
oh I got the cockroaches on the screen
nice
no there wasn't okay you're an idiot
I'll get away what is this
there's a leak can you say nope
I'm above the sewers and it's still
leaking [ __ ]
no I don't want to go down there
ah I'm confused
it's a lot of puzzles in this game
ten bucks sweet
I guess I gotta go down there yeah
but that still leaves me lost
can I jump there now I should yeah you
can
I don't think it's a good idea can you
jump in the game yeah oh you're gonna
see that day in tomorrow's part this is
a lot of jumping in that phone ah
tenemos
[ __ ]
I hate a man that is quite impressive in
many ways but
huh
I didn't work it's got to be something
with this thing
yeah
really money
let's try and get out there
text you remembering stuff sorry what it
takes
steady remembering stuff no it's that
Agrippa guy talking to me he doesn't
have a jaw but it talks to me through
that thing who he
that's him Tanya yeah he's gay
yeah that's [ __ ] thing there they
talk okay
no I stalking through that thing told
you and it kind of looks like that
monster did because the monster doesn't
have a Joey there I thought it was like
becoming a master or somebody that was
to
is there something I can like oh I can I
can use them it did work
oh no no no no
why can't I jump up there
there's a but I can't put my hand on
that all right I worked it out I didn't
even look at it what the [ __ ]
okay so the machinery is working now
that means I can go back up
solving puzzles without knowing it
that's
why am I wasting my oil god dammit
it counts the energy you're gonna have
to deal live with that
so who is likely after tortious there's
no torches to light
I guess there's one there you go how you
already wonder meet ya
who did you think was doing it hahaha
that would be nice actually maybe the
monster turns out to be like a total bro
or something should be working now yeah
it's not that's not nice at all that
means scared the stuff is gonna happen
beric
all right so we got the machinery
working but I still don't know like what
kind of machinery we started with or
something could you go to the motors to
able to see you scared right I think
Alexander is talking to me oh nice
no it doesn't sound nice at all
have you heard him before no I think I
did earlier but
baby's coming No
I hope that well I hope that because all
the doors are open now so how will you
kill a guy who at economy he's old and
weak yeah and you are young and strong
those the worst had skulls on them
before so let's go into the room that
has skulls on them
that's a good idea right oh [ __ ] it goes
in it oh [ __ ]
okay transect I've no idea what that is
what is that the noise scared the hell
out of me
oh well oh oh is that the [ __ ] water
monster I hate that thing
however never hear it again
okay
should we bring him up here or something
did it work no I just bit off the rope
probably put tar there it's our
get that [ __ ] know didn't work okay
I'm gonna go into transept
you know transit means
what transept chan
Jack wait I don't know the place I'm
going to now is called transit oh this
looks great
can you spell it for me tra and sepg ah
this place is horrible
publics corner of
this one prepare is a torture room
about damn it
uh-huh we're gonna go in here
oh so dark Oh
the cradle is ready Brod
you remind seal dried is lies any
attention
he cries like me
[ __ ] this
oh I think we got a part please tell me
it's a part no it's not it's just a
[ __ ] pyramid it's the old seeing yeah
I hear I'm hearing clocks I heard that
in the morgue can you see the white
light there
we're just hello white light all right
twice in screen probably but I found
something piece of orb yes
did it feel like Dora the Explorer I
have to go we did it we did it it's
texture and color are constantly shaming
I hate that those clocks Kwok sounds
wait-wait-wait-wait-wait